j'accueille jacques séguéla
voici
trop fort a dit mme ben là c'est à dire
non alors il y avait bernard tapie m'a
dit qu'il allait de casser la gueule tu
t'étais pas ça va à jacques oui 71 en
effet vous allez avant après 71 ans
vice-président damas le publicitaire le
plus bronzée de france plus le produit
vieillit c'est la règle de la pub ici
que tu connais bien comme en plus le
produit vieillit plus il faut soigner
l'emballage
lille est un produit très bien implanté
on va vraiment lui qui disait quand il
était bronzé qu'il avait instigué la
reom vous faire rater le non non non ma
femme pourrait avoir sa voix quand vous
faites alors mais contrairement à ce
qu'on croit je ne prends pas de petites
gélules carotène gens ne prend pas de
carotène je ne me mettais h
je ne m'aimais pas sous une lampe
brothers c'est naturel voilà c'est comme
ça il faut que je suis parce que l'avion
en corse aussi je suis fils du sud avant
d'être finir un jeu alléchant alors
voilà ce magnifique donc des cas rien de
soleil à mon avis il doit sortir fin dès
qu'un peu de soleil je cours ouais moi
j'ai besoin depuis plus de soleil
faisait ggd qui n'est pas là c'est le
démon willer le soleil t'aimons viagra
mois et le viagra mais comme c'est son
célèbre encore
toujours pas toujours pas non allez jaja
jeudi par jal mais enfin qui déconne pas
de viagra j'comprends mais appelle ma
femme me dire très belle votre femme
sophie et très le meilleur deal viagra
c'est une jolie femme n'a pas de nom
c'est mécanique
c'est mécanique ça viendra peut-être
demain devenir tout à l'heure jusqu'à
présent tout va bien je suis donc
paniquez pas pas de viagra normal comme
sauvian paniquez pas pas de viagra va
peut-être faut-il en douce et qu'elle ne
s'est même pas dans la soupe
l'occurrence là où qui treize journées à
vue qui se présente le publicitaire le
plus bronzée de france n'a pas besoin de
viagra
oui vous êtes toujours un homme de
gauche oui alors pas besoin de viagra
non plus pour la gauche non si l'on
avait besoin
moi j'y crois je continue à y croire et
les banlieues des flammes derrière
sarkozy a abandonné quand tout brûle ben
oui il faut un peu de sarkozy puis en
parallèle il faut quand même un jour
qu'on a il leur tendre la main
après tout on est tous responsables de
ce qui se passe puis c'est très simple
ce sera l'intégration ou la
désintégration et arrivera bel et bien
celle là où il faudra comprendre que le
monde de demain sera métissée il faut
accepter ce métis d'accord il faut
rentrer dedans et c'est à nous à les
leur proposer on n'y arrivera pas mais
on a raté la première génération a
complètement raté l'intégration de la
première génération
c'est vraiment mieux qui l'avons ratée
c'est pas eux même si c'est pas bien de
brûler les voitures il faut pas rater la
seconde mais c'est un boulot de 20 ans
et puis le problème n'est pas là le
problème est moi qui tourne autour du
monde en permanence qui est cette chance
ça peut pas continuer comme ça ça vous
va continuer avec des pays riches de
plus en plus riches et du pays pauvres
de plus en plus pauvres et le jour où
enfin on n'acceptera nous tous les
risques de partager un peu que les
autres y aura de moins en moins de
problème d'intégration
c'est quand même ça alors c'est pas si
mal ce qui se fait même chirac c'est pas
ma tasse de thé mais il a commencé à
faire une première taxe
les avions c'est l'ami d'avion alors
sauf qu'il est le seul à le faire iliad
avions bien alors jacques séguéla vous
publié chez jean claude gosset vite tous
égaux à eux géo évidemment havas moi et
les autres vous raconter d'histoires de
havas à travers ses présidents
successifs jusqu'au dernier carré psi
lié à l'arrivée de vincent bolloré voilà
alors au départ havas est incroyable
s'était fondée par mail qui s'appelle à
l'asse sûr mais c'est en 1835 et le mec
à 110 ans le mec à deux idées pas mal la
première c'est de rassembler tous les
jours
les nouvelles du monde pour les vendre
aux journaux ce qui est pas idiot
deuxième idée le prix des annonces est
indexée sur le nombre d'électeurs a
inventé nodimat il avant tolima t il
invente aussi la régie 1
c'est à dire que il a des commerciaux
qui vont chez des annonceurs il leur
propose des toutes petites annonces mais
qui deviendront un jour des grandes
annonces et puis des annonces tout court
et son fils disant j'ai les créatifs
d'un côté des journalistes j'ai les
annonces de l'autre se dit mais pourquoi
pas inventé une agence de pub et c'est
au but ça va ce qu'ils inventent la
première à changes depuis du monde
la pub est une invention française et
voilà mes jambes a perdu 4 pouvoir pas
mal alors le fils vers son père il est
lui-même dirait par ses dauphins en
phase avec havas cette ellipse dallas
s'est pas abbas ensuite il ya un dénommé
rédier qui est compromis pendant
l'occupation allemande quand des
allemands sont arrivés ils sont alex et
havas ils ont pris la majorité
il restait président comme si de rien
n'était et puis en 43 il a dit mais il
ya belle au pea à faire sur publicis
et en plus c'est une agence marqué par
l'étoile jaune alors par bonheur les
allemands n'ont pas donné suite mais ça
s'est su et il a été viré de tout des
possédés et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs le
patron de publicis bretagne de chine a
toujours voulu à mort à abbas et pour
cause bien sûr
alors après jacques dousse en 1950 on
lui dit c'était plus un fils de commerce
qu'un fils de pub c'est un euphémisme
parce que c'était quand même l'époque
quand même vous le dites c'est un peu
les magouilles les financements
électeurs
les filiales familiale toute dernière et
puis après il va y avoir zéro qui va
arriver et kiffa andré rousselet avant
ce genre où il ya le plus main président
vous allez un peu vite parce qu'avant il
ya un mec qui s'appelle georges requête
c'est jean paul 1er qui s'est suicidé au
bout de 40 jours pourquoi il a vu les
conséquences si c'est une histoire
d'argent si c'est une histoire d'amour
et la mise en scène est tellement
dramatique 1 qui s'est assis dans un
fauteuil seul chez lui il a pris un
fusil de chasse qu'il a mis dans sa
bouche et il a relié à une ficelle à la
poignée de la porte d'entrée et il
attendu que sa femme ouvre la porte pour
partir en fumée
histoire c'est pas mal c'est sûr que
même dans un film sympa pour la
maintenance et sa magie c'est le gars un
couple apporte qui culpabilise toute sa
vie parce que là tu laisses enfers
terrible alors andré rousselet
effectivement ensuite andré lebon s'est
lui aussi comme vous ils les écuries
d'havas soon augias qui aborde canal+
alors ce mousse les il est remplacé par
pierre dauzier en fait il est tué par
balladur d'où le fameux article du monde
edwards matt eu évidemment voilà alors
vous allez peut que jacques séguéla vous
êtes à la tête d'une agence qui sapent
qu'est ce qui se passe rien oui mais oui
venait c'est comme si de rien n'était
une bonne idée donc à l'époque jacques
vous êtes à la tête d'une agence qui
s'appelle rscg qui est une agence
indépendante que vous avez créé avec
bernard ou et pour vous l époque
havas c'est le monstre à battre c'est
votre ennemi d'ailleurs quand havas et
achète veulent s'emparer de tf1 au
moment de la privatisation vous créer un
fonds du refus mais elles sont là vous
avez un milliard de francs de dettes et
vous êtes obligé de vendre votre agence
rscg à votre pire ennemi
abbas et visitent ses plus beaux jours
de ma vie moi j'ai fait dix ans de boxe
thaï et la première chose que vous
apprendre que tu ailles chaque fois d'un
coup vous souriez pas vous seriez et
c'est ma méthode
plus ça va mal plus judicieux le plus
aujourd'hui quand je croise en plus en
jalles déjà on est tous couler moi
j'étais dans la pub à l'époque
c'est havas moi je savais bien été posée
immortel et un jour j'ai put blé vous le
revendez la boîte et vous dites c'est le
plus beau jour de ma vie mais ça l'a été
parce que grâce à cette absorption
d'abbas
j'ai pu arriver à mon rêve qui était de
voir la publicité française rayonnait
dans londres mais voilà ces deux joyaux
net à 71 ans on peut tout dire ils
s'étaient pas le plus beau jour de votre
vie jacques mais je sentais que j'étais
au bout du rouleau avec mon agent ce que
c'était une chance extraordinaire que on
allait pouvoir réaliser tous nos rêves
et après tout que ce soit sous la marque
arrêt cg sous la marque havas la marque
publicis moi mon patron c'est la pub est
d'ailleurs car ils ont de dire à mon âge
on n'a plus besoin de moi oui car il ya
que deux moments où on n'a pas besoin de
mentir quand on est riche on en a rien à
[ __ ]
et quand on est vieux on en a attiré la
foule et quand on est riche on ne
comprend rien pas de viagra
non alors le même scénario d'un village
de couleuvres ccam reproduit cet été
quand bolloré approche havas vous dit
cette déstabilisation et dévastatrice
vous êtes à ce moment là parfaitement
solidaire avec le président de l'époque
qui s'appelle alain pouzilhac et vous
dites si alain 120 je m'en vais aussi et
vous êtes toujours là j'ai pas dit ça
j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit si bolloré doit
nous dépecer et novembre à un groupe
étranger
amar classe râle qui est le grand groupe
anglo saxon je serai solidaire de la
neige on irait et j'étais à deux doigts
de le faire jusqu'au jour où j'ai
compris ce jeu vous êtes restés non pas
du tout je pars et c'est le jour où j'ai
compris que vincent bolloré allait
rester et à partir de là mon rêve
continue
et moi mon patron c'est ni plus cia qui
bolloré mire les rousses les digues
messier j'ai lu mon battement patron
c'est la pum kankankan voyais arriver
bolloré vous dites c'est terry mon ami
poupou tout j acques mon ami boo boo et
bien maintenant c'est mon ami bolobo
l'eau mon ami beau mais c'est pas grave
jacques conçoit opportuniste le che de
la reconnaître
je n'ai rien quand on le porte unis ça
ça fait avancer les choses mais c'est
pas du tout ce qui s'est passé
bolloré c'est docteur jekyll et mr hyde
un qui rentre dans une affaire une fois
y rentrer
au constructeur une fois en rentrant
raider pour faire être bien quand il est
rentré là tous étaient persuadés qu'ils
faisaient un raid il y a mis la manière
de raideur et donc on a tous été
solidaires devant allah et puis il n'a
cessé de dire qu'il était là pour durer
il a déjà mis un milliard d'euros 700
millions sera ce samedi les gens des
sciences mais aussi à vélo aujourd'hui
en parler mais oui assez chiant quand ça
arrive comme ça je sais ça fait tout le
temps oui j'aimerais bien voir votre
livre dédicacé après s'il ya de 30 ans
européen alors gang
il aura donc l'arrivée de bo l'oreille
c'est l'arrivée de bolloré c'est encore
une fois le plus beau jour de votre vie
quoi oui bonjour mais si si on veut
durer 11 et sur meu durer dans ce métier
qui est difficile
ouais bah il faut que chaque jour soit
le plus beau judo d'autrui moi j'ai
compris ce qu'était la vieillesse 1
je lui donnais le truc à naufragés de
gaulle oui se firent que ça la
vieillesse commence lorsque les regrets
l'emportent sur les rêves
vous l'avez revue pouzilhac j'ai revu et
il m'a dit écoute on a fait des jaloux
tandis que la vérité la bastille j'ai
revu plusieurs qui m'a sauté au cou qui
m'a dit tu avais raison bolloré
d'administrateur donc je le vois chaque
fois qu'on a un côté administration
la première fois on va serrer la main et
puis la seconde fois il a relu
d'ailleurs le livre avant que je le
publie la seconde fois il m'a dit quand
on a vécu treize ans formidable ensemble
on va pas se disputer des meilleurs amis
allemands
voilà